so with daredevil season 2 coming out
this week what I wanted to do here is
spend the next several days running over
the miniseries titled Marvel Universe
vs. The Punisher and what I'm hoping is
that at the end of all this you'll have
had a pretty good time but also have a
better understanding of how Frank Castle
deals with being one of the last
surviving humans on earth as well as how
this story differentiates itself from
the one-shot comic Punisher kills the
Marvel Universe so the model universe vs
The Punisher was a four-part series
written in 2010 by Jonathan Mayberry and
was designed to isolate and highlight
the one-man-army concept of Frank Castle
as it had been established by writer
Garth Ennis what I mean here is that for
those of you who have not seen my video
on the Punisher explained which you'll
find in the description prior to enos's
run on Marvel Knights Punisher in 2000
and 2001 as well as a sort of Punisher
max vol 1 in January of 2004 most of
Frank castles stories in the late 1980s
leading up to the mid-1990s
were largely considered one-shot
contained within a single volume while
this allowed writers the freedom to
depict Frank castle in different ways
ranging from team ups with and against
major heroes as well as focus on efforts
in subduing criminals the problem with
this method of storytelling was it it
took away from creating an immersive
environment where the reader could
literally track the actions of Frank
castle over time while Ennis had been
slowly building towards this idea with
Marvel Knights which served as a way for
Marvel to outsource their publications
amidst the near collapse of the comic
industry in 2004 when Garth Ennis
launched plenty sure max because the max
line of comics was designed to be a
DeLorean 'td the violence nudity and
language contained within allowed Ennis
to literally provide fans with the
Punisher series they've been waiting for
this combined with the fact that Garth
Ennis is first match run spanned 75
issues and was composed of 13 story arcs
all of which maintained a secular
continuity the cohesiveness of the
Punisher series came together to form
this wholly celebrated story that
elevated Frank Castle from an antihero
restrained by decency to an absolute
wrecking machine cutting a swath of the
criminal underworld and a hail of
bullets and blood now while Mayberry was
restricted a bit and that the Marvel
Universe vs The Punisher was not part of
the Marvel max line ended
allow him to depict acts of gratuitous
violence and carnage this story still
maintained elements of punisher max in
terms of the darker nature and the
melancholy tone of the story dealing
with the collapse of society having said
that as we get into this one of the best
elements of Mayberry's writing came in
the form of Frank castles monologue by
way of the War Journal to sidetrack here
the concept of the war journal dates
back to 1988 with a series Punisher War
Journal designed to be a companion to
the main Punisher series in that war
journal was essentially a sequence of
entries regarding Punishers missions who
was killing and why because the concept
proved to be so popular within the pages
of the main Punisher comics Malo began
the process of including war journal
entries explaining his current exploits
outside of the events within the war
journal line of comics that said in this
alternate reality the mission of the
Punisher is to track down and attempt to
kill deadpool something he spent the
last two days trying to do in addition
to this the problem Castle faces is that
while he has killed Wade 32 times before
which included burying burning dropping
him into a river and even weighing him
down with rocks because of his healing
factor and because an unknown individual
keeps freeing him Wade keeps reforming
himself where he goes on to Todd Castle
in a cat-and-mouse game now where he is
finally successful in capturing Wade and
cuts him into pieces believing that if
he buries them in separate locations
it'll keep Wade from reforming maybe
retakes the opportunity to provide us
with a backstory of what had happened
leading to the world ending up the way
it did what we're told is that somewhere
along the line punisher had killed
daredevil and while both matt murdock
and wade had been a part of whatever
laid waste to the planet
neither of them were the catalyst
traveling back to the first signs that
something was wrong
castle tells us that prior to the
collapse of everything spider-man and
rhino had engaged in a fight with one
another where their battle had stretched
several blocks in new york leading to
Madison Square Garden and interrupting a
Rangers hockey game instead of standing
down once rhino had been defeated
spider-man actually began to eat him now
regarding this bit of storytelling
Mayberry is actually drawing from two
elements the first is the Marvel Zombies
event and the second is the inherent
nature of the human community in the
Marvel Universe what I mean here is that
with Mayberry having contributed to the
Marvel Zombies landscape with the
Wolverine tie-in which focus on Logan
during the zombie Civil War
within the comics themselves because
spider-man was so popular as a hero the
initial response of humanity was that he
was defeating a well-known villain in
front of their eyes
something many of them had only ever
seen on television while the Fantastic
Four had been called in and were able to
subdue Peter in the days following the
incident as the world's foremost
scientist Reed Richards had been
answering a series of questions from all
directions as to whether or not it was
an isolated incident and if Peter had
become a zombie
now the influence of the Marvel Zombies
series came in that with Peter not
really being a zombie instead his mind
had been altered in a way that resulted
in him devolve into an animalistic state
in addition it is the idea of
spider-man's actions being an isolated
incident were proven false when Frank
Dux also known as the blob had gone into
a Chinese restaurant and consumed every
human being inside following this and
over the course of the next several days
the pattern of cannibalistic behavior
among Marvel's heroes and villains
continued to sweep across North America
with a daredevil consuming several nuns
as well as humans themselves being
affected and attacking other humans now
again the final step in maybe rediff ur
n chi a ting this store from the events
of Marvel Zombies is that instead of
simply consuming flesh these cannibals
were actually waging war on one another
using human remains as decorative pieces
and taking on a culture similar to the
primitive Germanic tribes during the
days of the Roman Empire
another Frank hassel himself while the
internet blacked out after a month in
the wake of utilities failing in society
collapsing small groups of heroes and
humans emerged in an effort to stave off
the cannibals and consolidate the
remnants of society where most of these
groups were short-lived in that castle
Wolverine and Rogers had fought together
and Susan storm had attempted to keep
her family protected when Rogers became
infected castle had put him down and
Susan storm had killed valaria and
Franklin once they turned as well
continuing to fast-track the history of
events castle tells us that somewhere
along the line Ben Grimm had formed a
tribe within the remnants of the Baxter
building taking Carol Danvers and
Polaris as wise where he also consumed a
large majority of people while castle
was able to destroy him after spending a
year amassing enough armament to pull it
off name of the Submariner had killed
those humans taking refuge and ships and
Thor had simply left for Asgard after he
was forced to kill the infected warriors
of areas and Hercules now our mayberry
had left things largely ambiguous
regarding how it was that punisher had
survived so long
it's the cannibalistic heroes with
powers this question is answered when
castle winds back to the events before
the start of the infection what he tells
us is that at some point he had come
across information regarding the Russian
mafia engaging in an arms deal with a
Middle Eastern extremist group involving
a possibility of a suitcase nuke while
castle was able to break into the
warehouse and interrupt the arms deal
after engaging in a firefight and
killing all those involved he was
splashed with a biological weapon of
unknown origin now the reason for
Mayberry including this bit of writing
is to point to the inherent flaw of
Frank Castle himself what I mean here is
that when Castle discovers the criminal
activities of nefarious individuals
within Marvel Comics he does not usually
take the time to investigate what's
happening and why instead he simply
arrives at the scene and if he witnesses
a crime taking place he kills everyone
and walks away
as a result Castle does not take into
account the issue of collateral damage
and the idea that his violent acts may
have unforeseen consequences
seeing this to its fruition within the
story after the collapse of society and
while investigating the chemicals
himself Castle learned to the biological
weapon was an unfinished experiment on
how to survive in an environment
following global nuclear war or some
other kind of unspecified calamity to
this end the chemical modified the genes
of humans allowing their bodies to adapt
to virtually any environment allowing
them to breathe any kind of toxic
atmosphere but also consume virtually
any material in order to keep their
bodies alive now while Mayberry does not
provide a direct answer as to why castle
had not succumbed to cannibalism he
instead offers a theory picked by Hank
McCoy stating that because frank castle
had been hit with such a heavy dose of a
chemical his body had essentially formed
an immunity to all forms of illness and
disease without the side effects of
cannibalism now again because castle
didn't give any thought to the aftermath
of his actions instead of calling in a
hazardous material crew to clean up the
mess instead he simply left as a result
the chemical made its way into New
York's water supply due to its ability
to survive in any environment to this
end the chemical itself was spread
throughout the crops and food sources
all along the eastern seaboard where it
was consumed by virtually everyone in
the country well not all individuals
became cannibals due to their immunity
to the infection once the scientific
community became aware of the fact that
the chemical had spread across the
country
because it had been developed in a
private lab none of the scientists knew
what it was or how to handle it now
during this time and because those
becoming cannibals were considered
isolated incidents with a New York
containing JFK International Airport in
fact that individuals were continuing to
travel internationally not knowing that
they were infected which led to the
illness spreading to every corner of the
planet however once the infection began
to hit the mainstream after Peter
Parker's incident because a chemical did
not provide any symptoms of its presence
beside cannibalistic behavior in
primitive actions the early attacks were
attributed to violence related to the
economic downturn or violent videogames
but as more and more scientists operated
under the leadership of Richards and
investigating the infection after
tracing the chronology of the attacks to
their source the world's top minds
including hank pym beast Adam Brashear
Victor Von Doom and Reed Richards
himself had all come to the realization
that while they had figured out the
cause of the infection because it had
been spreading around the world for a
year it was virtually impossible to
react in a way that would maintain
society as they knew it and so was the
first issue comes to a close we continue
with Frank castle as he works a track
down spider-man who he considers to be
patient zero or the first person to be
infected with the virus but also openly
admitting and coming to grips with the
fact that because of his negligence he
had essentially killed the world with
that being said we're going to bring
this video to an end I hope you guys
enjoyed it and let me know down in the
comments section what you guys think
about this story so far because to be
honest I think is probably one of the
best stories from Punisher in a long
time and I will catch you guys later
peace